Again, the judgement that women face
regarding whether or not to have children
reflects the societal pressures that are rooted in long standing
patriarchal norms. This is a judgement statement.
I am selfish if I want to have children.
Don't think that this judgement is immune to
any sort of societal pressures
that you feel
just the way that the choice to have a child is not a man.
So let's start with talking about the choice to have a child.
So women disproportionately to men
are judged for exercising their right to have a child
due to external pressures in modern times
such as climate change, overpopulation,
other environmental concerns for the economy.
In the same token,
women are pressurized to have children for the economy, I.
E. Baby bonus,
baby boom. So
it's women who are often expected to balance personal aspirations
to start a family with these concerns about our future
and what am I bringing my child into
and all of that. Sometimes people see children as inflicting life
non consensually upon someone.
Let's talk about the choice to not have children.
Again, women are judged for not having children,
also called selfish, strangely,
for wanting to focus on their careers
or just wanting to indulge in a life that is child free.
For whatever reason,
people see women's natural role as the role of a mother.
And therefore, when women
question that or choose to live differently to that social norm,
they are critique judged. But my point is that
it doesn't matter which way you're judging a woman,
you're still judging a woman.
And either of these judgements,
either of them reflect rigid gender norms with proper patriarchy.
So my point is not that is not selfish either way.
It's not to judge either way
because either way
you are perpetrating patriarchy through proper government,
rigid gender roles and believing that someone's uterus is political
and key to solving an external
social and environmental problem.
The women are then in what is called a double bind
where it doesn't matter what choice you make,
you're not free. I believe that at its core,
these judgments reflect a desire to control our bodies.
So if you're pro, pro choice,
then you should be pro choice.
If you're pro choice,
then you shouldn't be saying having kids is selfish
because you might as well be saying having an abortion is selfish.
And I don't know, maybe you do believe that.
But if you're pro choice,
you have to take into consideration what that means morally.
And that means free to make a choice without that type of judgement.
Stop holding women and people with uteruses
accountable for societal problems.
We should be holding governments
and large resource companies accountable for climate change,
not women and people on an individual level.
If you really think that judging women
for having a baby is gonna solve climate change,
it's the same as people thinking that controlling women's right
To abortion is going to solve the economy.
You need to look closer
because it sounds like you just wanna control women.
You wanna continue to control our agency
and make sure that we exist in a,
a bind where we can never win.